Disney's live-action Beauty and the
Beast is a gorgeous reimagining of the
beloved 1991 classic and it's loaded
with callbacks and easter eggs to the
animated movie that many even casual
viewers will notice but the new movie
also includes many delicious details
that only super fans might spot the
first time around
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm going to reveal 17
Easter eggs and details with only real
fans will notice in the new Beauty and
the Beast and by the way I'll be
including some fascinating facts for my
interviews with Beauty and the Beast
director Bill Condon and composer Alan
Menken about how they use deleted scenes
characters lyrics and dialogue from the
original animation in the new movie just
before I start I'm giving away this
amazing Disney hardback book from DK
which is loaded with behind the scenes
artwork photos and information about
Disney's live-action and animated movies
over the years for a chance to win all
you have to do is subscribe and leave a
comment about the new beauty in the
beasts movie or your favorite Easter
eggs from the film and for bonus ways to
enter check out the gleam link in the
video description below ok quick warning
there are spoilers ahead so if you've
not seen the movie yet why not check out
my spoiler free review then come back
here after you've seen the film when
beef suggests pal uses an enchanted map
to travel to the one place has always
wanted to see the destination she choose
this is a lovely nod to abusing the
beasts cameo in another animated movie
can you guess where I'm going with this
yes Belle and beast
travel to Paris were be suggesting visit
not true Dom all of which is very
exciting because Belle popped up in
Disney's animated feature The Hunchback
of Notre Dom where in typical Belle
style she walked along the street while
reading a book there's an interesting
moment during the opening song Belle
where Belle inquired if monsieur jean
has lost something again and he replies
that he believes he has he can't
remember what's given that Emma Watson's
best-known role before beauty in the
beef was Hermione Granger in the Harry
Potter series this feels like an homage
to the scene in the first film the
Philosopher's Stone where often never
gets his remember all he says to her
mind if he can't remember what he'd
forgotten
although Harry Potter fans may well love
this line Beauty and the Beast director
Bill Condon has said that it's a happy
coincidence because the real reason that
is Jean can't remember why he's
forgotten is because of the Enchantress
spell
how it made the town's people forget
that the castle and enchanted objects
ever existed
so what Jean can't remember here is that
it actually mr. Potts and his
conversation was balanced and clever
foreshadowing for the reveal later on
that he's married to mrs. Potts
perhaps it somewhat unfortunate
consequence of the change dialog that we
never got that brilliant line from the
original where the baker rudely
interrupts bells aligned Marie the
baguettes because he's bored of
listening to her talk about the book
she's been reading in the new movie
Belle's conversation with monsieur jean
replaces that conversation with the
baker but there's an odd with a twist to
that moment as bell still gets brushed
off but this time it's by monsieur jean
when he says that the book she's
returning to para birth sounds boring
john's line is also a joke at the
expense of the story of Romeo and Juliet
which is a book that bells just do
reading in this film and also the ones
who taught the beasts to read in the
original animation in the new movie the
Beast also pokes fun at Romeo and Juliet
when he introduces belt his library
saying that there are so many things
that are better to read the naturally
Experion tragedy about heartache and
pining Jean Cocteau's 1946 film La Bella
la bete is one of director Bill Condon
favorite movies and he found it a source
of inspiration for his own 21st century
remake of the story for instance as the
different steps up to the 1991 movie for
Belle's father in this version Maurice
has taken prisoner by beast for picking
a white robe given Condon's love for the
French films his use as a white rose as
a hat tip to Cocteau's film where
Belle's father is caught by the Beast
when he takes a road from beasts garden
the idea for which itself came from the
original mid 18th century French story
and buting the beast filmmakers included
a nice Easter egg on a marsh to the
author of that very first beauty in the
B story Gabrielle Suzanne bubbles evanov
when they named Belle's hometown view
nerves
shortly after maurice enters the beasts
castle seeking shelter
cadenza the heart' because' dot playing
be our guest
but suddenly stops when maurice goes
into the room this is a delightful
easter egg to the fact that in the
animated movie be our guest was
initially actually going to be performed
by the enchanted objects for maurice
rather than for Belle my arrow cadenza
who's married to the opera singer Madame
de Garda Rob and becomes a hottie called
under the curse is a new character
created to the live
action adaptation but cadenzas inclusion
this film is still a hat tip deville
nerves original story as well as Tula
plans to Bauman's adaptation a few years
later both of which feature beauty
playing a heart he caught in her own
home and also revealed that beefs have a
harpsichord in his castle on top of that
my era cadenza is also a little musical
a march to the 1997 direct-to-video
mythical Beauty and the Beast the
enchanted Christmas in which the main
villain was the music conductor and
composer maestro Forte who became a pipe
organ during the curse the live-action
film makes this connection when just
before be our guest
Cogsworth requests that cadenza play
quietly and cadenza replied sort of odd
sure of course
sotto voce and Forte and musical terms
which are basically opposites of each
other which is fitting because cadenza
is a good character and Forte was a
villain
the songs in the new Beauty and the
Beast also include tributes to variety
of classic musicals so be our guest
director Bill Condon has confirmed the
new musical number includes over a dozen
references including West Side Story
singin in the rain
cabaret and Chicago which Condon wrote
the screenplay for as well as nods to
Esther Williams and Busby Berkeley both
of which also influenced the 1991
version plus is also a little reference
to Moulin Rouge that star dia McGregor
who plays Lumiere in Beauty and the
Beast when Disney were going through the
music archives of the animated film they
came across some original lyrics by the
late Howard Ashman which didn't make it
into the final film back in 1991 so
director Bill Condon decided to put them
to good use in his live-action version
and when I interviewed Condon recently
he told me that they're the last lines
that Emma Thompson sings of mrs. Potts
when she reprised as the beauty in the
beef song at the end of the movie which
are winter turns to spring famine turns
to feast nature points away nothing left
to say Beauty and the Beast
but that's not all folks when I
interviewed Alan Menken recently he told
me that some of Howard Ashman unused
lyrics from the 1991 movie also made it
into the live-action version of the song
Gaston
stop with my quiver we shall appeal say
a prayer first I carefully aim for the
liver and I shoot from behind that spare
I don't care
by the way Menken told me that those
works didn't make it into the original
film of sneaking up and shooting an
animal in the liver was probably a bit
much for a younger audience
music foxes play an important part in
the new film as well father Maurice is
an artist who makes them but they're
also a callback to the animated feature
in early draft of the 1991 script with
his pots his son chip only had one
sentence of dialogue and the other
scenes where he appears in the film as
we know it today were going to feature
in his place a music box character which
spoke only by making little chiming
noises but when the producers realized
the movie was benefit from a child's
perspective they increased chips roll
and got rid of the music box character
after chip says his famous line from the
original animation Mumma there's a girl
in the castle he followed it up by
asking mrs. Potts
what kind of key the girl likes and then
lists a few different types including
Carmyle which is a delicious easter egg
- the original name the film makers were
going to give the talking teapot in
their animated movie yes back in 1991
mrs. Potts was very nearly named mrs.
camomile after the soothing herbal tea
but the filmmakers decided to go with a
name we know and love today as they
thought camomile might be difficult for
young children to say towards the start
of the movie we see Belle teaching a
young girl to read and pointing to a
page with a blue bird on it the page
says the blue bird that flies over the
dark wood which is a nod to the blue
birds that fly over the wood at the
start of the animated movie and also to
the blue coloured bird that appears
during the song something's there when
we hear that song in the original film
Belle is trying to bring out the beasts
gentle aside by encouraging him to feed
the birds in his garden at first they're
all scared away with the exception of a
little blue bird who jumps into his hand
by the way look closely at what Belle's
wearing as she teaches the young girl
and you'll see that her cardigan has
blue birds embroidered into the pattern
after Gaston and the foo finished their
big song and dance number at the tavern
Gaston complements his loyal sidekick on
how great he is and asked how is it that
no girl has snatched you up yet and the
few replies with a nice Easter egg -
frozen saying that
I've been told on cleany but I really
don't get it Josh GAD of course plays
both Lefou and frozen Zola an adorable
snowman who just loves introducing
himself to the movies human characters
with the line hi I'm Olaf and I like
warm hugs and is also happy to melt for
the right person as well as being a
frozen Easter Egg most foods reply also
foreshadows what the movie's director
has called a character's gay moment at
the end of the movie just outside the
tavern doors there are two wooden
carvings of wild foreheads and wanted
used by the angry mob to try and RAM
down the door to the beasts castle
although this is a change from the
animated film where the villagers chop
down a tree to batter the beef store
it's actually a really nice hint to the
design of the beast
wild boars one of the animals that
Disney artist Glen Keane took
inspiration from when he was creating
the animated beef look in fact if you
look at the beast in the 1991 movie
you'll see that he has the tusks of a
wild boar but long before Disney's
much-loved classic the Beast was already
associated with boars back in the late
19th century for example the English
artist Walter crane portrayed the beast
as a wild boar and his illustrations for
children's picture books
speaking of boars the coat of arms in
the beasts Castle consists of a lion a
boar and the lettuce WD just as boars
influence the beasts design in the
animated movie so too did lions with the
beasts having a lion's mane as for the
WD monogram that's a nod to Walt Disney
when Bella surprised that beast is able
to complete a quote she says from
Shakespeare's A Midsummer Night's Dream
explains that he had an expensive
education this is a change from the
animation were the beasts has trouble
reading it's also reference to the role
that made actor Dan Stevens who plays
the Beast famous in the popular period
drama Downton Abbey Stephens character
Matthew Crawley also enjoys an expensive
education which included a private boys
only boarding school followed by Oxford
University and intriguingly that's
mirrored in Dan Stevens own life as he
too attended a private boarding school
before going on to study at Cambridge
University at the end of this movie Bell
looks at the prince and asks how would
you feel about growing a beard which
director bill condon told me is an
unused line of dialogue that lyricist
Howard Ashman came up with for the
animated classic
interestingly enough Glen Keane who
designed the animated Beast for that
film didn't want the Beast to turn back
to the prints at the end the movie so
had page O'Hara who played Bell record
that line about the beard so of course
back then they didn't end up using it
now I'd love to hear if you spotted any
other Easter eggs or interesting
references in the new Beauty in the
Beast movie and how do you think it
compares the original animated classic
don't forget to comment and subscribe
for your chance to win this awesome
hardback disney book coming very shortly
I've got more detailed breakdowns of
Beauty and the Beast so be sure to turn
on your notifications of flicks in the
city and you'll get those as soon as I
post them and in the meantime tackle
click anywhere here for some more videos
you might like thanks for watching and
see you next time yippee-ki-yay movie
lovers